hello thank you for the warm welcome
I'll be talking on the kind of little
bit softer sides
considering the talks we had before on
different tracks mainly about the
management side by no means I'm not a
guru of management I'm one of you so I'm
machine learning engineer software
engineer and so on and so forth I just
worked on many projects and led some
groups and I have some thoughts about it
because we have a big problem we have we
have great people and the industry we
have great frameworks we have a lot of
tools we have a lots of hardware but
still we have problems with our projects
and this is kind of a cool it's not
totally full collection of what I've
learned I just want to start a
discussion and share some thoughts with
you about it it's on the software side
you don't have to be a manager to do it
it's also for if you are a developer or
software data scientist machine learning
engineer you can take some things from
that because I'll be talking about the
processes I'll be talking about teams
are we talking about data so many things
by the way how many of you are actually
can be considered some form of managers
can be line managers team leaders or C
as well okay so like 1/5
I guess cool anyway I hope I won't bore
you to death then so anyway
Who am I short introduction is more for
kind of prints you can contact me via
Twitter Linkedin and these slides will
be on my github so there will be a lot
of references but you can download them
from a github later is to be software
developer and then I did some math HD
and then it's called now data scientists
or machine learning engineer so I kind
of to that but I have a slogan I code I
do maths so both both of that so if you
want to chat about it with me that's
that's cool and also I'm I used word
educator because I didn't got used to it
because I
teach both at university also in kind of
commercial setting as well and also
sometimes give a talk places like here
so I'm guessing educator a little bit as
well anyway this is what we have now so
depending on what you read a large
number of in kind of data world because
I'm not distinguishing now big data
machine learning data science and so on
so forth basically projects that have
some form of data wrangling in it fail
this is kind of that the reason of
failures and how they fail and if
differently sometimes just get postponed
they get not used but large number and
failure is it bad per se well first of
all no it's not bad because you don't
have to or shouldn't think about machine
learning like it's not like building a
house it's if your project fail that's
actually good sometimes because I mean
in its it's closer actually to science
so in science we like to fail because
we're actually proving that we wrong
more often that proving that we right I
mean we're actually mostly proving that
be wrong so first of all the big number
is not that bad it means the problem
hard but also we have many additional
problems in the industry and they're
mostly managerial kind of related or
organization related problems that make
project fail and this is because
basically that they stop working
oh it works out I think okay I think I
switch it off anyway okay so looks
familiar to you so many times you
probably felt like this guy here that
you're kind of doing something but it
kind of feels wrong so so technically we
are kind of moving forward but the means
of transport is not great and why that
happens so I will tell you why the
process differ I will tell you a little
bit still talking about who are you
anyway so what's machine learning and
what's the data science and what do you
need a new project I show you what we
cannot see really what are the cost of
the problems what should you look for
and how the team defers and I kind of
try to structure this talk in kind of
problem solution kind of idea because
not to just get into a round saying that
oh everything's bad it's more just you
know everything is bad but we can we can
fix it somehow so okay bear with me so
first of all about the process so you've
probably seen some of these graphs in
kind of this shape or form the first one
is what is called crisp DM and it's
quite old actually as well and the other
one is scrum and so we have circles
there but that's where the kind of
similarity stop so on the on the right
oh sorry you're left sort you you have
the you have Chris diem so how usually
we conduct the data science project and
it's a cyclical project process around
the data really so first of all we talk
to business then we have some data
understanding data preparation modeling
evaluation and deployment and that's
kind of is getting done in the circles
most of the time that the big difference
my colleague reminded me is historically
when this got told because
VMs here stands for data mining so
that's quite old so historically when
people were taught that the problem here
was that each of the blocks tend to take
like three months or something like that
nowadays it's actually got agile you you
actually do those iterations very very
quickly but
in most of our projects related with
data we have to do all the steps whereas
scrum it was designed for it's like a
factory so basically you'd know what
you're building and you just want to
kind of modify it and push it as fast as
you can so as you can see here in the
scrum you don't have for example
business understanding part or data
understanding part you just have to push
forward so that's that's the idea of
scrum and this is why in many
organizations scrum fails I don't want
to say that scrum is bad or something
like that it's just it's designed for
producing things we know how it should
look like so basically like web pages so
this button should be blue and do this
we know what we're doing whereas with
data is we have at most hypothesis that
we're saying oh there is some value in
this data that we can prognosis our
prices or something like I hope Rob
knows our demand but it may not be there
or or it can be something completely
different so we're we scrum how we plan
the scrum is it's quite a problematic
for data science teams and often data
science and machine learning and big
data teams are kind of pushed into the
scrum without the understanding of that
this this is so the crisp or this kind
of data cycle is the real process how we
work work with the data and there is
much into it as well there is also one
thing that is a little bit of
misunderstanding kind of curry
career-wise which I have moved forward
to as well in the next slide is that a
lot of data-driven problems are not only
technical problems they are related to
organization they're related to people
we actually talk a lot so actually
people working with data have to talk to
business people and that's a little bit
of a cliche nowadays in the IT industry
that you think about developers like
people closed in the cellar and coding
whereas it's not a fact in in like a
data world really because if you do that
you basically get business people the
answer they already know most of the
time okay so that's the so the process
differ so we should use slightly
different processes oh the answer here
is anticipating that question
agile is not bad per se just scrum
doesn't work too much too well with the
later
for instance we use Kanban quite often
and it works much better because you're
much more flexible with Kanban than with
scrum so that's that's the answer here
next who actually is data scientists or
machine learning engineer or data
engineer and so on so forth
often company very much overlooked who
they hired for and what necessities they
have so this is actually what kind of
the broad data team should look like so
we starting from kind of data analytics
and then data science you know well I
hear I kind of distinguish because
people say oh what's the difference
between data analytics and data science
I use the kind of comparison that data
analysts work at the data they know
what's in the data and data scientists
work on the data that they don't know
what's in the data basically so that's
the that's the main difference in my
mind at least and okay but what how how
they differ from machine learning
engineers machine learning engineers are
people that actually have more in common
with data data sorry the data engineers
and and software engineers and sometimes
DevOps engineers that basically take
models that they know they're kind of
good and they torture it to a level of
kind of then being good and useful for
the business so you don't necessarily
have to do a lot of data science thing
and reports and so on and so forth you
just have to push the model to the limit
and that's kind of the definition the
modern definition of machine learning
engineer versus data scientist I'm not
saying here this is the dead Venn
diagram so you have a overlaps here so
it's not like your if your data
scientist you will not torture the model
or you will not deploy it that's not
true it's just depend on the company but
you will probably spend more time on
understanding data if your data
scientists and more time on torturing
models when you're a machine learning
engineer and also when you're in machine
learning and you deploy it and give to
the production guys then some back end
will be involved some Devils will be
involved and some data engineering will
be involved and this is actually when
you look at those those diagrams
this is pretty much the mature dates a
team you will need in your organization
so if you have just one or two bits of
this kind of diagram you will likely
fail because you're missing something
because data scientists or even even
machine learning engineers are not
really good DevOps for instance so
that's you have to remember about it ok
going kind of more deep into it this is
kind of more reminder or me saying that
read this paper basically there is nice
paper which is from nips from three
years ago I think I don't remember
exactly it's called hidden that with
machine learning systems and this is
what they show this is that kind of the
most interesting and most kind of
expressive picture of how the system's
really worried look like and the stuff
we're super excited about is that the
yellow one in between and we talked
about this a lot I mean we want to have
the best models they are and so on so
forth but actually most of the time we
spend on the engineering stuff so when
we want to deploy the models so bear in
mind that for example in an organization
when I listen to like Amazon or Google
talks they say from that they only do
modeling for well the models machine
learning models they only do for like
five to at most 20% of the time and rest
of the time is some form of data
wrangling or deployment or coding in
general so that you have to remember
about that and you should have all the
blocks here so I I don't have time to go
into it in detail so just just go and
read it but it's very very informative
also they spend quite a lot of time of
what we've heard today already there the
problem of garbage in the garbage out so
they machine learning and data problems
are notoriously bad because if you make
a carrier in your code it will throw you
an exception if you make an error in the
machine learning model it will return
the number so I mean in sense of if it
gets a data in a form that it kind of
expects but the data is totally
different data than you expected before
you'll get a number but it means nothing
so you have to remember about it as well
okay how you can work your way around it
I mean first of all you know hire people
with different skills so that's one of
the thing and the second thing is okay I
know you're focusing it out don't you
can get it on the internet it's called
it used to be called big data landscape
now it's called an AI landscape because
big data's that you just have data now
so basically if you have quite a lot of
tools you can use and I encourage you to
do that go go to your favorite cloud
provider find your favorites to online
for modeling for data deployment for for
model deployment and so on so forth a
lot of stuff has been done and it really
really will help you to move forward
especially if you think about production
was some data data projects in a
production fashion okay the other stuff
I jump kind of over with whom we do it -
what we're actually doing so man versus
machine there is a lot of conversations
of the we had a talk about it how AI how
models influence our our worlds in our
days and actually this kind of have been
done in the past so if you think about
it and I'm not talking about the
research I'm talking about industry now
so in industry what we are actually
doing is we are automating things that
people are not very good at or are bored
at or are just expensive to to use there
so so that's that's actually very kind
of similar to a factory optimization
ultimate automatisation I think
automation oh sorry - a factory
automation that has been done in like
the hundred years ago instead today we
don't have like a harsh working
environment we have people that have to
read for example social media instead we
can do it automatically using machine
learning and by the way you can get hurt
reading a lot of social media so but
then how people think about the models
is a bit problematic because really what
models are is this tree example here by
the way you remember what was it that's
who you've seen it so that's Titanic air
it's not very useful in industry but
basically it's it's a process so our
based on our kind of decisions or basis
or some numbers models can can say oh
it's a or b or the plus a plus B oh this
is some number or so on and so forth
so models basically what they do they
automate relatively easy human processes
into code well our algorithm statistical
models and so on so forth but the people
kind of think times about the AI or the
models as being like something
supernatural
we often get like questions like we are
monitoring brands on the internet
questions like oh if you can detect the
logo so can you detect if we for
instance with the beer if we pour the
beer into a glass can you detect what
the beer what's beer in the glass and we
know can you detect what beer is in the
glass if you see it basically in the
glass well you can't so models can do
only things that people are able to do
and we have to think how we're actually
detecting because also the human
perception is quite tricky so we also
have a question with like when you have
like a typical bottle or something like
that can we detect if it's turned it's
like yeah but that's not a label
detector that's a bottle detector then
so that's different model so you have to
think about it so basically what we have
to do is build a a factory to some
extent that automates relatively simple
people's tasks which are well defined
and and make them to run faster than
humans can do and in kind of more
reliable way I wouldn't say I'm biased
because that data can be biased but more
reliable way all right and what you
can't forget about it won't be cheap I
mean probably if you do like simple
modeling like I don't know linear
regression is sufficient that's that's
going to be cheap relative you just need
a laptop for that but if you want to go
into some fancy stuff like natural
language processing or image that will
be expensive that's an example you may
or may not her excellent at is say from
Facebook is transform a light model it's
like kind of Burt on steroids let's say
and this is what they've paid for
training them I mean there is no price
here but I can tell you it's quite
expensive I mean depends in this
Tiku you can read depends on the
estimate on which cloud they did it all
which hardware they used they spent from
like tens of thousands of dollars to
like sixty five thousand dollars or for
one model training so this is kind of
like one experiment so that's that's a
lot and you have to remember about it if
you go into if you go into this type of
project you have to remember that they
will be expensive and you have to take
it into account also also you have to
remember about the data so that's that's
another kind of expense people tend to
forget about it and you know nowadays
it's quite cool that you have all the
open source stuff or open datasets and
so on so forth but a lot of time they're
good if you're kind of distinguishing
Golden Retriever from Labrador but not
all the businesses are into it so your
business may be into I don't know cars
or something like that and so there is
no data size of distinguishing either
for it makes of course or something like
that so you probably will have to
construct on your data set not
mentioning NLP that for example
Wikipedia is quite cool but Wikipedia is
not the language that people use or
social media or in email or something
that I Wikipedia is very specific to how
the language is used and actually you
don't have any dialogue well you have
some dialogues there but they may also
be ancient so so you have to remember
about it that a lot of data set won't
fit your business problems you have to
spend time and money and actually think
about it how how to make your data sets
when you embark on that on a data
project and again that can be also a
engineering problem but that does by the
way open image no sorry that's the open
image it's in its net sorry example and
we could be there as well so okay so the
you have to assume that there is no no
data for your problem and you have to
find it you can use transfer learning
and tune your data but still you you
will need like one or two or ten or
really like few thousand examples to to
be often hunt labeled by people you have
remember about it so how you can go
around this so one thing is transfer
learning a lot of existing models for
especially for full NLP and images there
is a lot of stuff out there you can use
them but you have to remember that the
existing models were most of the time
trained on those academic datasets and
they're great at Labradors and great at
Wikipedia language but not necessarily
great on your weird social media very
short conversations or sing single
emojis and stuff like that yeah and also
you have existing models so all the
cloud providers or all the big cloud
providers and a lot of smaller companies
have some form of AI API so you can use
and basically you have to know how the
rest call works in a language basically
to use them it also it's very simple so
start from there if you get more fancy
you can go into this in Auto ml business
that you can provide a small data set
and train them instead of kind of
embarking on full-blown data project
because if you do you probably sing
quite a lot of money into it so try
stuff first
build the hypothesis test it on existing
tools then embark on kind of longer
scale data projects and team
team-building and also you have to
remember about that that's the bookshelf
part of my talk you have to remember
about that there is a lot of kind of
cavities out there and traps for you and
some of the traps are in the statistics
so and Matsu you can look into AI
delusion or quite controversial weapons
of mass destruction about you know what
are the traps of using models in
different practices and how they are
biased and what can this can cause on it
but also your enemies yourself so
Thinking Fast and Slow is a great
example of how human minds work and how
our kind of biases and ill understanding
of statistics will kind of mislead you
so you have to remember about that as
well so you have to use things like
hypothesis and really scientific method
to some extent to actually work in this
field it's not again building a house
it's more of
art in science kind of business and and
don't forget about it all so I want to
kind of just just scratch a surface with
different types of of teams because
that's a big big area how to lead the
teams of data people data scientists a
lot of people in the business have PhD
PhDs they're quite creative and these
are quite different things than I don't
know factory workers or something like
that so you have to and a lot of on the
other hand management stuff was built on
19 and 20 century theory of management
in like factory based industry so
they're kind of obsolete so so you have
to kind of move over it and these are
the books I can kind of recommend for
you to read radical candor I think it's
a must for everyone and I see if
thinking about how to lead people and
how to talk to them and how to make this
your communication with your people in
an effective way
creative thing is very interesting is
from the creator of Pixar and he
actually transitioned from academia to
to industry because the stuff that did
in Pixar was super new and that was
actually transferring a lot of academic
knowledge into industry for the first
time and they have a lot of ideas how to
work with super creative people because
the people that I work in in there this
is like a definition of being creative
so so they have a lot of tricks how to
do it and also organization wise
blitzscaling is quite interesting though
that it's actually very business here
and how you scale scale your business
but also how you how to think about the
your business in your business size kind
of setting so that's a recommendation
but the bottom line here is those themes
are slight a little bit different and
you have to read them in kind of more
open way and they have to have a lots of
freedom basically to move move around so
a lot of people tend to forget about the
typical or kind of let's say
conservative approach to management
doesn't work with these
these teams and these people okay thank
you very much questions any question
from your side regarding the managing
data-driven ad okay
speech and have you ever had chance to
work with external client on on AI or
data related project or this was always
something no yes yes I did so not always
internal it was all the consultancy
products or so what would you recommend
to in a way of explaining risk and
possible failure of data project the
client you have to learn quite a lot of
jokes that's the first I think but well
I think what people I don't think
business is unhappy with failure per se
they just want to know so they want to
understand how the failure will work and
how you can kind of react to the failure
relatively quickly so long story short
radical Condor so just being being
basically honest and explain what's the
plus was the minus and what you're
getting into it in approachable way I
mean I think the problem with business
is not the they don't understand the
risk is just how we explained explain it
to them because often I had this
situation I was talking to director in
in a company not a technical guy
completely and he was saying like oh we
had this data scientist people and they
were explained like throwing numbers on
me and all I wanted is a list of phone
numbers to call clients that that's all
I I wasn't interesting in that so how
you communicate your certainty or
uncertainty and what the business need
that's the most important thing and I
think if they understand what are the
steps roughly and what can go wrong down
and you know they they're relatively
happy with with the the risk and also
should be agile in sense of they want to
have results relatively quickly so I
don't know should I say MVP I said but
yeah but basically work on a kind of
prototype basis so you should quickly
show them something how it will roughly
work they're not interesting that
interested that you know your precision
is just 60% or something like all point
six whatever but are they interested in
you know this is what we will get and
they will kind of assess it and we also
what we did often is we prepare demo for
clients that they can use kind of when
they come back basically so so so
basically they can click and you know
use the model for instance like with
sentiments and they can chuck some text
into it and you know they say oh this
works great or not so something like
that so so just you know be honest and
let them see how your model works I
think okay thank you
transparency for doing right yeah so
thanks so much thank you a coop
[Applause]